- Just labor is not going
to get you somewhere.
The right kind of action, the
right timing, right place.
All this is important, isn't it.
The events around you may
not be determined by you,
but how your experience
of life is on this planet
is 100% determined by you.
Believe me, you're not
going to be here forever.
I will bless you with a long life,
but you're going to fall dead one day.
If you're beginning to
think that what you're doing
is very important, you
need to take a holiday.
You cannot fight, or you cannot overcome
that which does not exist.
We have fixed too many
things on the outside.
If you fix anymore, there
won't be a planet left.
- He's an Indian yogi mystic
philanthropist and author.
He founded a nonprofit organization,
which offers yoga
programs around the world.
He also founded Project Green Hand,
a grassroots ecological
initiative in India.
He's Sadhguru, and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules for Success.
My personal favorite clip is number seven,
so I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best.
- Effort has to be incisive in a sense.
It should be focused, calibrated.
Simply if you make effort,
it's foolish effort, isn't it?
Just labor is not going
to get you somewhere.
The right kind of action, the
right timing, right place.
All this is important, isn't it?
So for all these things to happen,
you need perception and intelligence.
So that's all you must do in your life.
Constantly looking for ways
to enhance your perception
and your intelligence.
The rest will anyway happen.
This is one thing that, unfortunately,
humanity is not doing.
They're trying to become
capable of something.
They're not trying to
be capable of something.
Just enhance your
perception and intelligence.
Can you see me right now, all of you?
Can you see me?
Just point out where I am.
Use your hands and point out.
Can you see me?
Oh you got it wrong.
You know I am a mystic.
You're getting it completely wrong.
Now this light is falling upon me,
reflecting, going through your lenses,
in order to imagine you're 80 now.
You know the whole story, right?
Where do you see me right now?
Within yourself.
Where do you hear me right now?
Where have you seen the whole world?
Within yourself.
Have you ever experienced
anything outside of yourself?
Everything that ever happened to you.
Darkness and light happened within you.
Pain and pleasure happened within you.
Joy and misery happened within you.
Have you ever experienced
anything outside of yourself?
No, so what I am asking you
is what happens within you?
Who should determine how it should happen?
What happens within you?
Who should determine
how this should happen?
Somebody else?
Definitely you should determine
what should happen within this, isn't it?
So if you determine what's
happening within this,
your whole experience of life
will be determined by you.
Nobody else but you, isn't it?
The events around you may
not be determined by you,
but how your experience
of life is on this planet
is 100% determined by you
if you take charge of this.
If you leave it loose, just
about anybody will determine it.
They will.
Not consciously.
They also like you by accident.
If you just observe, if
everybody makes a little effort,
everybody take a little time
for this piece of life, okay?
Not for your family.
Not for your career.
Not for something else, something else.
Just for this piece of life.
Give it little time because
this is the most important piece
of life in your life, isn't it?
Yes or no?
- Yes.
- Even if you are in love with somebody.
Still, this is their most
important piece of life, isn't it?
So pay some attention to this.
How does it happen?
Why have you taken it for granted?
Believe me, you're not
going to be here forever.
I will bless you with a long life,
but you are going to fall dead one day.
Yes or no?
- Yes.
- So do not take this for granted.
If you wake up in the morning,
tomorrow, if you wake up in
the morning (audience laughs).
It is not my wish, but I want you to know,
of all the people go
who go to bed tonight,
over a million people will
not wake up tomorrow morning.
And tomorrow, if you and me
wake up tomorrow morning,
is it not a fantastic thing?
A million people did not wake up.
You woke up.
Is that not a great thing?
Just look at the ceiling and smile.
You are still awake.
YOu're still there.
And for many many millions of people,
somebody who is dear to
them did not wake up.
So just check those five
or six people around you.
They all woke up.
Wow, it's a fantastic day.
You woke up, and everybody who matters
to you around you woke up.
is it not a fantastic day?
You don't think so.
- Yes.
- You don't seem to think
so because the problem
is just this.
You are living with an
idea that you are immortal.
When I say you're immortal,
you're not actually
thinking you're immortal,
but you're not conscious
of your mortality.
If you are not conscious
of your mortality,
somewhere you think
you're immortal, isn't it?
How many moments in a
day are you conscious
that you're mortal?
If you are conscious, would
you have time to crimp?
Would you have time to
fight with somebody?
Would you have time to do
some rubbish with your life?
If you knew, if you are
conscious that you are mortal,
you will do nothing other than
what is absolutely needed for
you and everybody around you.
This one thing if you do,
if you just remind yourself,
don't think this a negative thing.
Death is not a negative thing.
It is the only thing which
has added value to your life.
If you are here forever,
you would be unbearable.
(audience laughs)
We ought to be glad that
everybody does one day.
If you just become
conscious of this thing.
That always you are
conscious that I am mortal.
You don't have to think I will die today.
We don't intend.
We want to live as far as possible.
Just you know one day I will die.
If you're just conscious
of this one thing,
you will naturally become spiritual.
Every day, every moment
if you remind yourself
this is a brief life, I am
mortal, one day I will end.
Just do this for two days and see.
You will become something
truly fantastic within yourself
just as a result.
- That is simply beautiful.
- That is all that is needed.
If you want to know the value of life,
just know that it's a brief happening.
Just loosen up your life a
little bit, laugh a little more,
involve yourself with people around you.
Do things that you think
is not so important.
Don't do things which are very important.
Do simple things.
It's very important you do simple things.
Very important things you
are doing in your life
you will become very serious.
You know Bertrand Russel, an English man.
Bertrand Russell said if
you're beginning to think
that what you're doing is very important,
you need to take a holiday.
So holiday does not mean coming to India.
Holiday is every day.
In those 24 hours, you must take a holiday
from your seriousness, from yourself.
Seriousness comes essentially
because of your self importance.
You hold yourself as an important person.
I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust
in this existence.
Tomorrow morning if you disappear,
for sure in India, nobody will miss you.
Even Down Under, they won't
bother much, you know.
A handful of people, they
will also forget soon enough.
Isn't it so?
Woof, nature does woof, you're gone.
And nothing will happen in this world.
Everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not there.
Every human being should be aware of this
every moment of his life.
It does not matter what the
whole world says about you.
It does not matter how
significant a work you're doing.
You must understand that tomorrow morning
the world will go on fine without you,
whoever you may be.
Isn't it so?
If you constantly remind yourself of this,
you will have no reason to
be serious (laughs softly).
Definitely not dead,
and don't be dead now.
The time will come.
It's time to be alive.
To create fear, you have to
use excessive imagination.
To not be in fear, you
don't have to do anything.
Fear is happening because
of excessive imagination.
Things that have not
happened, you are creating.
What may happen in your mind
happens in thousand different formats.
And most probably never happens.
The things that you
fear, the kind of things
that you have feared, probably
99 of them never happened,
isn't it?
Yes.
So your fear is about
that which does not exist.
You cannot fight or you cannot overcome
We can overcome something that exists.
You cannot overcome that
which does not exist.
You just have to just give up that effort.
Enjoy the fear.
After all, it's your making.
You like horror movies.
You're saying no, but
you're producing them.
It's just they're not making
money, that's all (laughs).
(audience laughs)
Fear means you are producing
horror movies in your mind.
Nobody else is willing to watch.
That's bad for the producer.
But you're producing them.
So you produce something else.
Produce a comedy, a love
story, suspense, thriller.
Try and see, today.
Just sit down and produce a
love story, a suspense thriller,
a comedy, five-minute movies
you make in your mind.
Really, start using your mind differently.
It's gotten into your pattern.
Just gotten into pattern of
just creating horror movies
all the time.
You have watched enough
horror movies, they're boring.
Create something else.
It's not that if you produce these movies,
these things will happen in your life.
Still they may not happen.
At least you enjoyed the movie.
In reality, it may not happen.
So what.
At least you enjoy what's
happening in your mind
if you cannot enjoy what's
happening in the world, isn't it?
That much privilege every human
being deserves, isn't it so?
Even though the world is not kind to him,
at least his own mind
should be kind to him.
Should produce some nice noise.
We are completely committed to
one dimensional intelligence,
which we call the intellect.
Which is just the thought process.
Thought can only happen with the data
that you have gathered
through five senses.
Which is very limited, one thing.
And another thing is the nature of data
that the senses gather are only
useful for survival process.
The very nature of how you see things,
how you hear, smell, and
taste, and touch life
is only relevant for survival process.
If you're wanting to know the life itself,
then these instruments of
perception are no good.
Even what is light and
darkness is a debate
between you and another creature,
which sees darkness as light, isn't it?
If you sit with an owl
and start an argument
as to which is light
and which is darkness,
it's an endless argument, but
who do you think is right?
If you think both, you're
either in the diplomatic corps
or you have a successful
marriage (audience applauds).
- [Host] Some have both.
- You learn to say both
but which is the truth?
What I see as the truth and
what the owl sees as the truth,
that's not the point.
It is just that nature has
opened up our sense perception
as it is necessary for our survival.
Accordingly, it has opened
up sense perceptions
for different creates as it is
necessary for their survival.
But if survival is all you're seeking,
this is good enough, the five senses.
But once you have come as a human being,
somehow survival is not good enough.
If your stomach is empty,
there's only one issue,
about food, but once the
stomach becomes full,
you have 100 issues going
on (audience laughs).
So the nature of the human being is such,
no matter what you do, you
want to be something more
than what you are right now.
If that something more
happens, something more,
something more, it's an endless pursuit.
So somewhere, a human being is
seeking a limitless expansion
but trying to do it with physical means.
The very nature of physicality
is a defined boundary.
If there is no defined boundary,
there is no possibility
of physical happening in the universe.
But now a human being is
longing for the boundless,
that too in installments,
and through physical means.
Through the boundary, you are
trying to become boundless.
The desire is fantastic.
The method is hopeless.
(audience laughs)
Because the moment you identify
yourself with something,
your intellect's work is just
to protect that identity.
If you, whatever identities
of nation or family
or gender or race, religion, whatever.
The moment you identify
yourself with something,
your intellect will only
function around that
to protect that, so it is a certain type
of prejudice the moment you identify.
So the only thing I did with my life is,
I never identified myself with anything.
And life just exploded within me,
in ways that thought seemed so puny
that I do not indulge in
thought most of the time.
Pleasantness is a choice, isn't it?
So why is it so much unpleasantness
is happening in human experience?
Because we never took
charge of the inner damage.
We believe by fixing the outside
everything is going to be okay.
In the last 100, 150 years,
with the advent of science
and modern technology,
we have fixed too many
things on the outside.
If you fix anymore, there
won't be a planet left.
Yes?
Definitely this has
brought much convenience
and comfort to our lives.
In every way, we are the most
comfortable generation ever.
Do you agree with me?
- [Audience] Yes.
- I know you have series of complaints
about how things are not okay,
but we are the most comfortable generation
ever before on this planet, isn't it so?
- [Audience] Yes.
- But we cannot say we are
the most joyful generation
on the planet.
We are the most loving
generation on the planet.
We are the most blissed-out
Definitely not.
We are complaining like
crazy about everything
like never before.
This is because we fixed the outside.
Comfort and convenience has happened.
Wellbeing has not happened.
If your interiority was
handled by you consciously,
you would definitely keep
this in a blissful state.
So is bliss the goal of life?
No, bliss is a necessary condition
for life to flower to its full potential;
otherwise, it will remain constrained.
You're paying too much attention
to everything around you,
not enough attention to this one.
But the quality of your life
is essentially determined
by how you carry this one,
isn't it so?
This moment, what kind
of coat you're wearing,
what kind of car you parked outside,
what kind of home you live in
does not determine the
quality of your life.
This moment, how joyful are
you feeling within yourself
determines the quality
of your life, yes or no?
Nothing has been done about it.
You think it will happen in consequence,
and you're setting impossible
goals for your happiness.
If I have to be happy, my
wife should be like this,
my husband should be like that,
my children should be like this,
the world should become some other way.
Well, these are impossible conditions
you are setting for your
happiness and peacefulness.
Now that you have compromised
yourself to peace ...
Why I'm saying compromised
yourself to peace
is because a lot of people
have given up aspirations
for being ecstatic or blissful.
If I am just peaceful, it's enough.
Even the so-called spiritual
leaders are going about
saying peace is the
highest goal in your life.
Peace is not the highest
goal in your life.
If you want to enjoy your lunch today,
you must be peaceful, yes or no?
If you're not even peaceful,
there is nothing in your life
that you can do in a worthwhile way.
To be peacefully essentially means this.
That you are not messing your mind.
To be peaceful means that
your system is at ease.
You know how to conduct your mind.
You know how to conduct your emotions,
your body, and your energies.
You are peaceful.
It is not a rocket technology.
It is the most basic thing.
You have a dog at home,
you give him his food,
he sits peacefully.
Maybe not ecstatic, but peacefully.
Many times they are ecstatic also, yes?
If your dog is able to sit peacefully ...
Oh he doesn't have to run my industry.
That's not the point.
He's got his own stuff going.
(audience laughs)
See it has nothing to do
with the external activity
that you are doing.
It's got something to do
with the internal systems
as to how they're functioning.
Essentially it means neither
your body nor your mind
nor your chemistry nor your
emotions nor your energy
are taking instructions from you.
They are doing their own thing.
Once your machine is not in your control,
being peaceful is impossible.
I'll tell you, you get into your car,
and now you go there and
you want to turn this way.
You do this to the
steering, it goes this way.
Can you peacefully drive this car?
Can you?
- [Audience] No.
- No.
Anxiety is natural, isn't it?
This is what has happened to your vehicle.
It's out of control.
You've never done anything to find out
where the steering will
lead, first of all.
This is not that simple as a car.
This is a super super computer.
Now the problem is most people
have not even bothered
to find the keyboard.
They think if they do
this, somehow it will work.
When you're given such a
highly sophisticated machine,
if you do not conduct it properly,
it will cause many problems to you.
By accident it's working.
I want you to know this.
This is made this way.
If you hold your hands like this,
it will breathe one way.
if you just turn it around,
the very way you breathe,
the breathing pattern itself
changes in your lungs.
You can try it if you want
when you have the time.
This way, this way.
I'm saying everything that you do,
fundamental changes that are
happening in this machine
because it is such a
sophisticated machine.
It's more than a touchscreen.
If you just wish it, it will happen.
When you have such a sensitive
and sophisticated machine,
and you are operating like a blacksmith,
then being peaceful seems to be difficult.
Peace is not the highest
goal in your life.
It is the most fundamental requirement.
Don't ever set peace as the highest goal.
If you do that, you'll only rest in peace.
(audience laughs)
You must see to be
peaceful is the first thing
in your life, isn't it?
If you want to do anything
sensibly in your life,
if you want to conduct any
situation in your life sensibly,
to be peaceful and happy is fundamental.
Unfortunately, in many
ways, not just in the way
that I said now, in many different ways,
I would say 70% of
illnesses on the planet,
all kinds, are self created.
Even if you get an infection.
There is a way.
If you keep yourself in a certain way
physically and mentally,
the virus and the bacteria
will not work in the same way
as it works upon somebody else.
If you set yourself like this,
no matter what's happening, anyway,
I have to go do this, this, and this.
There's no break from that.
The last 29 years, I have not been able
to cancel one program because
I am running temperature,
I got a cold, I got this, I got that.
It doesn't matter what's happening.
What you have to do,
you anyway have to do.
You can't turn back on that.
Either out of your commitment
or you have a boss like that.
One way or another, if it
happens, then you will see.
You will not at all fall sick so often.
Because if you have temperature,
you still have to go.
If it's summer, you still go, right?
No a lot of people don't go.
It's a little hot outside,
they don't go and work.
A little cold outside,
A little raining and
they won't go and work.
A snowflake, they will not go and work.
This is just weather.
So for every change in weather,
if you have the comfort
of covering yourself in
a blanket and lying down,
once you create that, your
body will learn to fall sick
as often as possible.
If you just keep it this way,
it doesn't matter what it is,
anyway I have to go and
do what I have to do,
you will see your body
will just bounce back
as quickly as possible, even if it gets
the worst kind of infections.
So you just have to set the
necessary conditions for health,
necessary incentives for
health, both for yourself
and your children if you have them.
Do not set incentives for sickness.
I was speaking in
Nashville a few years ago.
I was just telling them a joke.
In the joke, I referred to God as Him.
Immediately a few ladies stood up
and said do you believe God is a man?
Woah woah woah, I know where it's going.
I was only telling you a joke.
It doesn't matter.
You said him.
Do you believe God is a man?
I said I was only telling a joke.
(audience laughs)
It doesn't matter.
So now there is an argument going around
in certain parts of America,
is God a man or a woman?
In India, we have no such problems.
We have a man God, we have a woman God,
we have a cow God, we
have an elephant God,
we have a monkey, we have a
snake, we have flying ones,
crawling ones, creeping ones, every kind.
(audience laughs)
Because it's a very wise culture,
we foresaw all the future
problems that may arise.
Who knows.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Murthy Vrn asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
This is a little bit
of a different Top 10,
so I'm still really curious to see
which of the rules had the biggest impact
on you and why.
This one goes a little bit
deeper, more spiritual,
so let me know what you
think in the comments below.
Thank you again so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.